sell me this pen how much time did you
spend with leader Cabrio I spent a lot
like what uh you know countless hours
you know hundreds of hours hundreds of
hours yeah 100 plus hours how did you
find him and how did he find you when
you were just just interacting together
oh either um you know by telephone in my
house or his house or
um out somewhere and uh we were just
literally he said you know one thing I
don't think people realize about Leo is
uh his his Excellence is not by it's
like he strives for it he works really
really hard and I think he was so
determined to suck every bit of
information from me and any any stuff
that wasn't in the book and sort of you
know what was on my mind just really
trying and I guess I you don't realize
how much he's looking at you because
when I saw it on screen I was like oh my
God I like it was I I thought his you
know I was in a it was mind-boggling to
see my good friend Mr Jordan Belfort is
the single baddest [__] I have
ever met